(audience cheering)
Welcome back!
If you didn't know by now, I love all things flower.
I work under Flower Films, Flower Beauty, Flower Home,
Flower this, Flower that.
And I do think that having flowers in the home
can be a real mood booster and a total visual game changer.
But sometimes I spend money on flowers and then they die,
and then I'm sad and I feel like I wasted money,
so then I don't buy them for a while
and then I'm not living in that joy.
So there is something to dried flowers,
or the process of drying them,
that I wanted to talk about on the show.
And our next guest is a horticulturist and floral guru.
He's actually someone who I'm very close with,
he's helped me transform my home into a beautiful oasis,
some dried, some fresh.
And today he's here back with us again
for more flower DIY tips that you can try at home.
Please welcome Christopher Freimuth.
(audience cheering and applauding)
That's right.
So the last time you were here
you showed us some beautiful arrangements
using fresh flowers.
Take me through how we accomplish a dried flower look.
What are we doing today?
So some flowers you can just leave in the vase
and they just dry in place.
For example eucalyptus, stardust here.
And other flowers it's best to hang upside down,
so that when they dry in place, they dry nice and erect.
Now walk us through how to actually do that.
Teach me Christopher, teach us.
Yes.
So I just take a piece of chicken wire, crumple it up,
and I try to make it as messy as I can,
and then often, very careful with my fingers,
because I don't wanna poke myself.
So just kind of crumple it up and then we have one here,
you put it in your vase just like this.
I love this.
And then you can just poke your flowers into in,
and rather than having them flop all over the place,
they'll stand right up.
Are there any flowers that are better
in the dried flower realm?
Or flowers you should stay away from?
Like-
Yeah.
That'll get smelly and won't preserve,
lose all their color?
Yeah.
What's best in practice?
I would stake, you just brought over some lavender,
lavender obviously is the best.
Because it's not only beautiful but it smells great.
And these are strawflowers, which even when they're alive,
they look dried.
So they're really, really convenient.
Why do you think that it's more economically beneficial
also to love dried flowers?
Oh my God, I mean if I sent you live flowers
they'll last for a week.
If I give you dry flowers they'll last a lifetime.
What is a flower brooch?
What is a flower brooch? Let's talk about it.
So you can use your taller stems, just like you did,
in an arrangement like this, and if you have a bunch
of small stems, you can just use a piece of twine,
tie them together and then,
I know you're wearing one flower, but don't-
I just wanna demonstrate how amazing Christopher is.
Yours is so beautiful and mine looks nuts.
(Christopher laughs)
(audience applauds)
And all of these, are these the brooches?
Those can be used for brooches,
or in little glasses like that.
So that I may put in my windowsill in my bathroom,
on my kitchen sink.
And then a brooch, you have a little pin here,
you can just pin it right to your-
Okay. And the dried flower confetti.
Confetti, yes.
How do we do that?
So if you have lots and lots of dried flowers
you can make a big arrangement with the big stuff,
you can make a little brooch with the little stuff,
or you can also put the little brooch on a gift
that you've gift wrapped as just a little accent.
I love gift wrapping with some,
I love to take the bags I get from the grocery store,
the brown paper bags, cut 'em up, reverse 'em,
tie 'em together with some twine and put some little flowers
and then mark it with a Sharpie,
like to so and so-
Totally.
Love, me.
Yeah.
And then with your super extra stuff,
like dry flowers are very brittle,
so you're bound to sort of have petals and leaves
falling off all over the place.
So you can take those leaves and use it as confetti
at a party or wherever you want.
Then show me, demonstrate, like-
Demonstrate, let's see.
How would one show the confetti?
All right, ready?
Yes, do it.
Here we go.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I love that.
I also have to say,
I think this is such a beautiful centerpiece
on a dining room table.
Take a runner, that's something that's like a cloth linen,
take a wooden bowl, and look at how beautiful this is.
(audience applauding)
This is romantic to me.
Yeah, absolutely.
And it's funny, because I think sometimes
when you ave your flowers and they tend to pass away,
they get thrown out.
And I think there's a whole life to be lived there.
And the way that you've arranged flowers are so beautiful,
and the way they dry flowers.
I literally have Christopher arrangements
all over the apartment, that are just in preservation,
'cause they dry so beautifully.
They really do.
If you just put a little something next to your sink,
or bring a little color into your world,
it can stay there and spark joy, so I thank you.
'Cause we've been talking about doing this segment,
of how to preserve dried flowers.
Now if you go on our website, all these DIY floral tips
from Christopher will be on there, TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
Christopher Freimuth!
Thank you.
Thank you so much. I love you.
We'll be right back.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat theme music)